mais mon admiration c'est d'une certaine
façon c'est sans qu on ait voulu comme
ça mais c'est une bonne manière de de
savoir que quand parle d'immigrants
c'est pas les migrants c'est une
multitude de personnes certains sont
venus en cars 2 communautés comme comme
on le ferait de même les québécois de
souche canadiennes françaises sont allés
ailleurs dans le monde mais pas
construit unis reste on avait un grand
nombre d'entre nous comme cela s'est
fait aux états unis au 19e siècle
on se retrouve ensemble on partageait
les mêmes chômage surtout pas tessinois
passé rappelle notre histoire ça nous
permet de nous sentir ensemble alors
c'est sûr qu'il ya beaucoup de chèques
sont venus d'ailleurs qui se sont
retrouvés dans des quartiers mais aussi
des gens qui sont venus pour tout
simplement d' aventure des gens qui ont
fui des guerres qui ont fui des
catastrophes et réglementaire la
violence alors il ya des gens qui
simplement venez retrouver leurs
familles qui étaient déjà ici or c'est
sa mémoire immigration c'est de montrer
que les histoires d'immigration d'impôts
seulement une
c'est pas les chinois les portugais
c'est plein d'histoires dans toutes ces
communautés de et c'est aussi découvrir
que les immigrés ils sont arrivés à
montréal comme des français qui ont
fondé montréal comme les britanniques
sont arrivés après bizarre besoin de vie
comme tout le monde et ils ont créé des
petits commerces des entreprises
ils ont été et sont encore les artistes
des créateurs et c'est ça aussi c'est de
voir que depuis presque l'origine de
montréal montréal s'est faite avec la
part de jeunes qui sont venus d'ailleurs
et évidemment qui comme des premiers
français se sont joints à eux ont été
accueillis par les autochtones qui
étaient ici depuis des millénaires
c'est ça qui est fantastique d'histoire
de montréal cc milliers d'histoires qui
se rend compte des leçons d'histoire qui
dit la mémoire de montréal
c'est que toutes ces histoires là de la
plus petite à la plus grande
elle mérite d'être connue et elle nous
dit que nos préjugés souvent sont fondés
sur pas grand chose
est ce pas grand chose dont on veut ou
son histoire que ça devienne trésor pour
connaître la diversité de montréal et de
sa population et de ces ignares